the president met with a group of 23
World War II veterans family members and
volunteers and thanked them for their
service the veterans traveled to D.C on
an honor flight from Austin Texas to
attend the Pearl Harbor Remembrance Day
observance at the World War II Memorial
on the National Mall
these veterans served on the home front
across the Pacific and European theaters
today we remember and pay tribute to the
2403 service members and civilians that
died during the attack on our forces at
Pearl Harbor and honor the extraordinary
contributions that these veterans made
to guide our nation through the world's
darkest moments
I'd also like to offer an update on open
enrollment as of today nearly 5.5
million signed up for Health Care
through the ACA Marketplace since the
start of open enrollment last month a
continued record-breaking pace for
enrollment and quality affordable health
care the Biden Administration has made
expanding access to health insurance and
lowering health care costs for America's
families a top priority and under their
leadership the national uninsured rate
reached an all-time low earlier this
year
thanks to the inflation reduction act
which Congressional Republicans want to
repeal four out of five consumers can
find a plan that costs ten dollars or
less a month additionally 13 million
Americans will continue to save an
average of 800 bucks a year on coverage
open enrollment continues until January
15 2023 for States using the
healthcare.gov platforms Americans
without health insurance or those who
need to renew it for 2023 should go to
healthcare.gov between now and December
15th to ensure that their coverage
begins on January 1st 2023. we've also
got some really good economic news that
I know you all are excited about gas
prices have now hit their lowest levels
since January
the national average is 3.36 bucks per
gallon down about a dollar 66 per gallon
since June and about 18 cents below
where they were when Putin invaded
Ukraine in 11 states the average gas
price is 2.99 or less
that that decline is saving Americans
families with two cars about 170 dollars
a month President Biden committed to
addressing Putin's tax hike at the at
the pump and he is doing just that
finally this morning the president
signed the Speak Out
bipartisan legislation uh speak out out
act I should be clear there bipartisan
legislation that will enable survivors
to speak out about workplace sexual
assault and harass a harassment increase
access to Justice and make the workplace
safer for everyone today's bill was
passed thanks to part up to the
extraordinary leadership of Gretchen
Carlson and other survivors and
Advocates as well as Congress
Congressman Lois Frankel and Sherry
Bustos and Senator Kristen gillibrand
and Mazzy and Mazi hirono
one in three women report having sex
having faced sexual harassment in the
workplace and people of color low wage
workers and lgbtqi plus individuals are
also disproportionately impacted
individuals are also I'm sorry
disproportionately impacted
the threat of legal retaliation can
silence survivors while allowing
predatory workplace Behavior to continue
unchecked the Speak Out act creates a
critical National Standard empowering
Survivors by prohibiting the enforcement
of pre-dispute non-disclosure agreements
those are ndas and non-disparagement
Clauses in cases of workplace sexual
assault or harassment this bill Builds
on the ending force tributation of
sexual harassment sexual assault and
sexual harassment act which the
president signed into law earlier this
year which made it easier for survivors
of sexual assault and harassment to
bring suit in court and to avoid being
forced to to arbitrate their legal
claims together these laws help protect
the safety and well-being of Americans
or American workers and make our
workplaces safer fairer and more just
with that oh hi Josh how are you I
haven't seen you in a long time you said
that last time I feel like I don't see
you enough clearly clearly I miss you I
have I have a thousand questions go for
go
[ __ ]
on the Georgia Senate election with uh
Senator warnock's reelection having 51
Senate seats what does that mean for
possible changes and how the White House
approaches its policy agenda and
Confirmation process
so let me just I want to give you a
little bit of color on the call I know
some folks had some questions about
about how the call went so Senator uh
Warnock uh well first as you know the
president called Senator wanak last
night when we got back for Phoenix
Arizona uh and uh and Senator Warnock
thanked the president for the call and
they talked about their partnership and
the importance of their continued work
together in the months and years ahead
look uh what I would say to your
question Josh about what this means for
for moving forward when it comes to the
president's legislative agenda when it
comes to Democrats legislative agenda
it's that it gives us a little bit more
Breathing Room a little bit more ability
to deliver for the American people the
president has been very clear these past
almost two years that his main
priorities main objective is to make
sure that the American the American
public the American people when it comes
to the economy we build it from the
bottle from the bottom up middle out
giving people a real opportunities you
see that in his economic initiatives and
and priorities as plans when you see the
bipartisan infrastructure legislation
the inflation inflation reduction act
which I just mentioned at the top and
when you think about the American Rescue
plan the first big piece of legislation
that this president passed with only uh
Democratic votes which met the moment
that he walked into with an econ economy
that was uh really tanking and he helped
make sure that people got shots and arms
helped the economy get back on its feet
and we've seen these successes which in
the last two to uh two years again this
is going to give us a little bit more of
that breathing room to get things done
to continue to move forward with what
the American people want and they were
very clear in the midterms what the
American people want is they want to
continue the agenda that the president
has had the last two years and then
secondly on the National Defense
authorization it doesn't include a
military covid vaccine mandate is the
president's objection to removing that
mandate so strong that he's willing to
veto the NBAA so let me just first say
I'll answer that question but I do want
to make a few points here so I don't
want to get ahead of the process as we
know there's the there we know there's a
the conference language there's still
the legislative process that has to move
ahead on this and so again I'm not going
to get ahead of the of the vote or I'm
not going to get ahead of the president
but every year as you know the uh the
ndaa has some Provisions we support and
some we do not and what the president's
going to do is he's going to judge uh
judge this piece of legislation this
bill on its entirety when that occurs
again there's a process moving there's a
process that's happening and so we're
going to let that happen in Congress I
will note just to be very very clear
here what we saw what what we think
happened here is a republicans in
Congress have decided that they rather
rather fight against the health and
well-being of our troops than protecting
them and we believe that it is a mistake
what we saw uh what we saw happen on the
ndaa as it relates to the vaccine
mandate making sure our troops are
prepared and ready for service is a
priority for President Biden the
vaccination requirement for covet does
just that I'll add one more thing just a
just a little bit of a a point a data
point here so all of you have this look
before covid vaccine existed nearly 700
Department of Defense personnel and
service members died of covid almost 100
of them were active duty and so since
this past spring there has been one
death due to covet so vaccinations work
and save the lives of our service
members so we believe that it was a
mistake
I just want to go back to your um
comment on on breathing room that you
just said if you could with a look ahead
going forward layout for us or where you
think you'll have the most breathing
room
um is it specifically judicial nominees
kind of what's the list of so we have
been very clear that judicial nominees
isn't is a priority for this President
that's something clearly that we want to
move forward on and continue uh continue
our successes we you've seen the success
of judicial nominees as it relates to
This president's first two years making
sure that we have put forth a historic
amount of of black women to uh to um you
know two judgeships and so the president
wants to continue to do that our
nominations as well moving forward on
that so that is something that we have
said those are clearly priorities I
don't want to get too far ahead of what
the president uh is wants to do or what
that legislative process is going to
continue to have those conversations uh
Congressional leadership but again look
we saw we saw the results all of you
reported on on the results of the of the
midterms and you know the you know
Democrats and not just Democrats pardon
me but the American people were very
very clear on what they wanted to see
they wanted they want uh Congress and
the president could continue to fight
for women's rights and our freedoms they
want to protect our democracy they don't
want our social security or our Medicare
to be put on the chopping box and that's
what Republicans officials were putting
out there as their plan and so we're
going to continue to deliver for the
American people what you saw Senator
Warnock do and what you saw Democrats do
this past uh this past election is run
on the president's agenda run an agenda
that was successful uh and uh and so
that's what this was a success for
Democrats but also for President Biden
layout that agenda now given that the
results are in so if you could walk us
through the thought process behind that
when we then might hear the president
are we going to hear some kind of speech
on that and then just quickly um what
what is sort of the thought process in
terms of bipartisan agreement the
president after the midterm said that
working with a divided chamber would be
my life for Democrats more difficult
does he still believe that in what areas
where they're can you say that last part
again that the president had said that a
divided chamber in the Congress would
would make the reality for Democrats in
Washington working more difficult it
would be tougher to do your job get
things passed if you don't have a house
um what going forward what kind of where
where are the areas of bipartisanship
that you could so look there's so many
areas of bipartisanship that the
president sees when it comes to
delivering for the American people on
the economy on Health Care on issues
that they truly care about we can do
that in a bipartisan way there's no
there's no reason that that couldn't uh
be done you know we talk about the
government funding last year it was done
in a bipartisan way this year it should
be done in a bipartisan way because you
when you think about what's in the
what's what the specifics are in that
funding you think about public education
you think about public health right you
think about our national security all of
those things are not partisan issues uh
but I will also say when the president
had his meeting uh with the big four the
the Republican and Democratic Leadership
on Congress in Congress just last week
he was very clear he saw the readout and
you heard me say this as well which is
uh you know this past almost two years
there were more than 200 pieces of
legislation that the president signed
into law that were bipartisan uh that is
so it is possible to get things done the
president was in Phoenix Arizona we he
talked about the chips and science act
that was done in a bipartisan way to
bring back jobs to the U.S manufacturing
jobs in the U.S and under this
presidency more than 700 000
manufacturing jobs have been created so
there's ways to do that the bipart
person infrastructure legislation a
historic piece of legislation that's
going to fix our infrastructure and and
our roads are you know our roads our
tunnels our bridges and that was done in
a bipartisan way so there's many ways
that we can do that the president is
willing to reach across the aisle as he
has been during out throughout his
career to get things done for the
American people
again I don't want to get ahead of the
president uh I will let him uh you know
speak to that when the time comes what
I'm saying is the president is going to
continue to have conversations with
Congressional leaders he did just last
week just just a week ago or so and he
wants to make sure that we can continue
doing moving the country forward in a
way that helps the American people
uh thanks Korean so the the deadline for
Biden to decide whether to declassify
thousands of documents related to the
assassination of John F Kennedy is
looming it's December 15th
um is that the classification still on
track
um or will the administration seek I
don't have an update for you on that
particular uh question on Declassified
declassification of those documents uh
once we once we have more to share we
certainly will it don't have anything to
preview at this time one more thing um I
wonder if you can preview some of the
remarks Biden's going to make tonight at
the video for victims of gun violence
and he's spoken frequently on the
campaign Trail in public about the
desire for an assault weapons ban does
is that out of the water now that
there's Divine government uh well
there's 51 Central Democratic senators
now uh so that that matters like I said
it'll make things a little bit easier
but yes to your point uh is the divided
government but look far too many
Americans are losing their lives and
loved ones to gun violence we are seeing
communities being broken up families
being destroyed because of gun violence
and so tonight the president will join
survivors and families impacted by gun
violence to deliver remarks at the 10th
Annual National visual for all victims
of gun violence the vigil is a service
of mourning and loving remembrance for
all who have fallen a victim to the
ongoing epidemic of gun violence in
America as you all know as you just
mentioned a little bit about the the
assault weapons ban but also the
president signed the most significant
gun safety legislation in 30 years this
summer but it's feel he feels it's not
enough he believes that we need to do
more and he's been very vocal about that
these past several months he continues
to call for an assault weapons ban to be
passed by this by the Senate and send it
to his desk so he's never going to stop
showing up he's never going to stop
talking about this he believes that
speaking up and making sure that the
American public is aware what his
priorities are is important as well and
look and fighting for the scourge of gun
violence that is killing our kids
leaving holes in our families and
tearing up communities uh tearing our
communities apart so he's going to keep
continue to speak to that
in the way of the midterms the
president's traveled to two states that
were critical to 2020 but also where
Democrats did quite well in Michigan and
Arizona should we expect a trip to
Georgia a few times oh um don't have
anything to preview at this time on any
trips that the president will be having
in the next couple of weeks you know of
course we've been to Georgia many times
during even this presidency and always
look forward to going back but don't
have anything to preview at this time
can I ask in the funding negotiations uh
Republican leader McConnell yesterday
made pretty clear that they hadn't made
any significant Headway on any of the
major issues including the Top Line uh
and said that would likely lead to a CR
if it didn't change soon how does the
president view his role in his
negotiations I understand the critical
role Shalon to play as I understand
there are
the house Democrats to Democrats I was
probably against Republicans given the
timeline here what does the president
view as his role his necessity here yeah
well look just last week as I was
mentioning when he met he met with uh
Congressional leadership that was part
of the readout that we provided to all
of you is how important it is to get
this Government funding done uh he
believes and they just stated this
moments ago he believed that we were
able to do this in a bipartisan way last
year and we should be able to do that in
a bipartisan way this year we have the
time to get that done and to your point
yes our OMB director Shalonda young is
leading the process she was she knows
how to get this done she knows how to
reach across the aisle to get to make
sure that we deliver for the American
people these are not partisan issues
these are real critical issues that
we're talking about we're talking about
the different specifics of the
government funding that matter to the
American people so like I said the
president spoke to leadership last week
it was part of the readout that we
provided to all of you and he'll
continue to have those conversations is
the administration at this point
proposed to any CR into next year look
I'm not going to get ahead of what's
happening right now uh um in Congress
what we believe is that uh you know we
should be able to have an omnimus uh
Bill like we have done in the past and
it should be bipartisan and we have
enough time to get that done
okay uh thanks Craig is the White House
following the events in Germany in which
25 members of the far right group were
detained for planning to overthrow the
state and is the U.S offering any help
or intelligence gathering on that so we
applaud the German government and its
law enforcement and Special Forces for
their diligence and combating violent
extremism and keeping their citizens
safe and their government facilities
secure we would refer you to the German
government specifically and law
enforcement authorities for questions
about the investigation uh specifically
on that we remain in contact in close
contact with our government counterparts
and are standing by to assist if asked
uh also in foreign policy is the White
House concerned about Belarus moving
troops
um is their concerned that that might be
the opening of another front and
Russia's war against Ukraine so look you
know
um
we have been very clear about
um
about what is what Russia is doing right
we've been very clear that
um it is important to stand with the
Ukrainian people it is important to um
uh for us to help the Ukrainian people
fight for their democracy fight for
their freedom and that's what we have
done that's what the president has done
along with our partners and allies and
bringing NATO together in a historic way
and so that's what we're going to
continue to do and we're going to be
very clear and loud about that and and
say and say that we applaud what
Ukrainian what the Ukraine Ukrainian
people are doing and when it comes to
what we're seeing from Russia they are
they are you know they are the ones who
are attacking another country they are
the ones who are stepping on on their on
their freedoms on their democracy and we
have to continue to call that out and we
have to continue to make sure that we're
providing the assistance to Ukrainian
people to continue to fight so we've
been very clear on that we've been very
clear on it's important that folks stand
on the right side of history on this
when it comes to fighting art for
democracy and I'll leave it I'll leave
it there Belarus specifically so don't
have don't have anything specifically on
that I have not seen the reporting on
Belarus it would not be surprising as I
remember you all reported on Belarus
very early on in this uh in in this in
this continuous War but again the
president has been very clear like we it
is important to stand with the with the
Ukrainian people as they're fighting for
their lives as they're fighting for
their democracy and their freedom and
being on that side of History uh is is
incredibly important
thanks Kareem I want to follow up on the
vigil that the president's going to
attend tonight in the wake of the mass
shootings in Colorado and Virginia the
president said he wanted to revive his
push for the assault weapons ban where
does that stand is he going to push that
Millennium so look I just just uh
speak a little bit to why the president
continues to talk about this and I
talked spoke about it just a little
moments ago he believes that it is
incredible incredibly important as
president for him to continue to speak
to this for him to continue to put this
at the Forefront the importance of
getting the assault Vans weapon a
weapons ban and so and he he is grateful
for the bipartisanship that we saw just
months ago on getting that gun reform to
really fight gun violence something that
we hadn't seen in 30 years but he
believes we need to do more and he it's
not just the legislation it's also the
work that he has done throughout his
administration the president put out the
safer America plan which is a roadmap
for additional actions needed to reduce
gun gun crime as part of that the
president continues to call again for
assault weapons ban to be passed by the
Senate and he believes that is one of
the best actions we can take to reduce
gun violence and save lives and the
president feels very strongly about that
and whether it's in the next three weeks
or beyond the president is not going to
take his foot off the off the gas pedal
on on getting that done you know again
he's going to continue to talk about
that he's going to continue to make sure
that it is a priority for his
administration and be very clear with
Congress on how important it is to move
forward with this when we saw the
assault weapons ban in place 30 years
ago in 1994 when the president was very
much a big part of getting that done we
did see crimes go down as it relates to
uh to to that particular Bill and uh and
once it's Sunset 10 years later we saw
an increase so he's going to continue to
fight for it and I hear what you're
saying in terms of the timing I guess
part of me is curious about the
mechanism I had a chance to interview
him coming Congressman Maxwell Frost who
of course needed a key part of his
platform to fight against gun violence
and he caught has called for a vote on
the assault weapons ban in the Senate
saying quote I think it's important to
put it up for a vote even if it doesn't
pass because it gets people and I wonder
if the president shares that perspective
that it is worth putting it on the floor
for a vote the president I I understand
I understand what um what is being laid
out and said to me look the president
believes that we need to get something
done that's what he wants he wants to
make sure look he wants to see he wants
to see the Senate get it done he wants
to see obviously a vote in the Senate he
wants to make sure he wants to see the
assault weapons ban get done and he
believes that is what's going to save
the lives of of families and communities
across the country
ask you about the anti-Semitism form the
second gentleman said today there is an
epidemic of hate facing our country let
me be clear words matter people are no
longer saying quiet Parts out loud they
are screaming them obviously very
powerful words I'm wondering what if any
actions the White House the president
thinks Canon should be taken to deal
with this issue look the president has
been very clear
um you know I was talking to him about
this earlier today and uh look he said
he said what I've always said here is
silence is complicity right and that is
true and we need to speak out against
hate bigotry anti-Semitism and Holocaust
denial are disgusting and have no place
in America period let's not forget in
2017 the president put out uh put forth
an op-ed that that talked about what he
saw in Charlottesville and the hatred
the anti-Semitism that we saw that we
that you all recorded it on and so he
has been consistent on calling that out
talking about the soul of our nation
talking about how important it is to
really speak out against this type of
hate that we're seeing given how
critical it is to the president why
didn't he attend today why did you make
remarks look here's the thing that I
want to be really clear about again I
just talked about 2017 how the president
has been out front he was out front as a
former vice president he put out again
an op-ed being out front on this
critical issue and what we were seeing
and someone lost their lives right
someone lost their life on that day when
he decided to run in 20 in 2019 to be
president he talked about the soul of a
Nation he talked about the increase of
hate and what he was seeing and there's
been many times at this Podium and many
times this President himself has called
out the bigotry the anti-Semitism that
we have been seeing and he'll continue
to do that I talked about this how
important it is for the second gentleman
because of his story his history role
and how he belongs to that to the Jewish
community and how important it was for
him and again he represents the
administration he is the second
gentleman but look just a couple of
things I do want to lay out what we have
done at September's United We Stand
Summit our Administration announced a
series of actions and commitments to
take on hate field violence President
Biden has established the first
Ambassador level special Envoy to
Monitor and combat anti-Semitism and
appointed the re renowned Holocaust
expert to the role so these are actions
that he has taken most recently in the
last almost two years and I think that
shows his commitment to this issue that
shows his commitment in fighting
anti-Semitism and fighting hate
senator manchin now has an amendment to
the ndaa he's hoping to advance on the
floor
for his permitting reform Provisions
does the White House support and
continue to support the effort at this
stage so the president believes we must
pass the permitting Reform Bill so that
the that the U.S can realize the
benefits of the historic investments in
the inflation reduction Act and the
bipartisan infrastructure law he
supports permitting reform as I said
just a couple days ago we will continue
to work with Congress and find the best
path forward so we can enact a bill
enact this bill so it is a priority for
this president if I could just follow up
to your answer to Josh's question and I
think John Kirby said the same thing
this morning it was a mistake for the
provision rescinding the vaccine mandate
to be included in the ndaa but
specifically Josh asked you if the
president would veto the NBAA if the
provision remains is the president
threatening to veto the end I just
answered that question which was there's
a process in place we talked about the
conference language which there's a
legislative process that has to go go
forward right I'm not going to get ahead
of votes I'm not going to get ahead of
what that process is going to look like
the president's going to look at the NDA
in its entirety and make his judgment on
that and I'm not leaning anyway here I'm
just laying out the facts of how this
works
president he said specifically on
Thanksgiving that he was going to count
the votes to see if there were enough
votes to do anything during the lame
duck has he counted the votes has he
made any determination look I don't have
any determination to share with you at
this time what I can say is the
president is committed and believes that
we need to get an assault weapons ban he
has been very very clear about that he
is he's appreciative of what Congress
was able to do with the with the the
um the piece of legislation that got
passed just a couple of months ago on
making sure that we deal with uh gun gun
violence in our communities that was
something that we hadn't seen in 30
years but he believes we need to go
further again I I you know I try to
explain a little bit about his thinking
about how why he continues to talk about
this he believes it's important for him
as the President of the United States to
have this conversation to put this at
the Forefront and continuing to do this
because we're seeing what gun violence
is doing and how it's destroying our
communities and what it's doing to our
communities to make a determination on
votes in the lame duck
look there's there's a lot happening
right in the next couple of weeks I just
said whether this happens in the next
three weeks or Beyond uh this is
continues to be a priority for this
President the administ person following
today so we we've seen the reports and I
I believe the NFC the NSC team is
looking uh at that uh of course this is
a developing developing news and I I
don't have anything to share on that
today but again we've seen the reports
uh and NSC is certainly looking at this
okay
um Georgia elections official
bradfordsberger said yesterday that he'd
like to see Georgia
um lawmakers take a look at ranked
Choice voting or runoff Alternatives
does the White House have any thoughts
on the structure of State elections or
whether archaic election systems need to
be updated or changed so don't have any
uh position from the White House to
share on this today
um of course I've read the reports I
just don't have anything to share at
this time
train sorry to push again one more time
to follow up on Kristen and Catherine I
hear what you're saying that the
president has always and will always
wish for a ban on assault rifles I think
the difference is that he himself went a
step further and said in response to
whether that would happen during the
lame duck session he said I gotta make
that assessment as I get in and start
counting the votes so I guess my
question is I know you said a
determination hasn't been made but has
he started counting the votes are there
conversations between him and lawmakers
about where they stand so look
the president has always been very clear
to lawmakers that he has conversations
with how important it is to get the
assault weapons ban done that is
something that has been continuous and
that has happened across uh his
administration across a couple of months
of his administration that that will
never stop
uh you know I get the question and I
just answered I answered it and said
don't have a determination for you at
this time but what I can say is it
doesn't matter if it's the next three
weeks or beyond the president is going
to continue to fight for this right this
is something that is very personal to
him this is something that he worked on
as a senator and got done and let's not
forget you know we were able to see a
gun reform uh legislation or gun
violence a piece of legislation that's
now until law get done something that we
hadn't seen in 30 years and it was done
in a bipartisan way so the person the
president's going to continue to fight
for this he believes that getting this
done getting the assault weapons ban is
going to save lives and is going to uh
it's going to save communities and so
he's going to put this at the Forefront
continue to talk about it and uh and
work very hard to get that done
to him was specifically about these next
three weeks I so I hear you and I I
actually I just answered that question
can you just tell us whether
that process has started I I look I
don't have a I don't have anything else
to preview for you or if that process
has occurred or happened I hear what
you're saying I am telling you it is a
priority for this President uh he's
going to continue to fight for this
whether it's in the next couple of weeks
right of this of this uh uh of this
legislative session as we're you know
coming to the end of the year or Beyond
and what I can tell you for sure what I
can tell you for sure is he has
prioritized this it is a it is important
uh for him to get this done and uh and
again it could be the next three weeks
or Beyond we are going to uh we are
going to work very hard uh to get to
deliver this for the American people one
more on the the
new margin in the Senate now that the
vice president won't have to break the
tie as often
um in theory and she has more
flexibility in her schedule and time
will that impact her portfolio travel
schedule at all I I mean I don't believe
so no
I would reach out to her team
specifically but I don't believe so the
Pres let me just say the vice president
has been a great partner of the
president this past two years uh you
know the successes that they both have
had in the clearly Biden Harris
Administration on getting things done
for the American people when it comes to
the economy when it comes to lowering
costs when it comes to fighting
inflation and that is something that
we're going to continue to do we just
talked about the gun violence reform
legislation that was passed just a
couple of a couple of months ago all of
that was done in partnership with the
vice president and he appreciates all
the work that she has done on on on
these issues
Ukraine
um the White House and the president
were very vocal about Georgia's new
election law when it was signed in March
of 2021 and a big argument from the
White House was that it would suppress
voting but there was record turnout in
the primary there was record turnout in
the general record turnout in the runoff
in early voting absentee ballots and
in-person voting so is the doj going to
drop their lawsuit against the state I
can't speak to doj's actions and what
they're going to do
though called it Jim Crow in the 21st
century and a blatant attack on the
Constitution so does he still see it
that way I'll say this I'm not going to
speak to the Department of Justice legal
actions that's something for them to uh
to speak to what I can't say and uh not
not going to get into specifics of your
question but you guys you all reported
this that there was uh suppression uh
that uh that that we saw that uh
throughout through that throughout the
the Georgia election so that is
something that was been reported on so I
leave it to those reports but look
even with that the American people came
out they came out in a historic faction
fashion uh to make their voices loud and
clear when it comes to democracy when it
comes to protecting our democracy when
it comes to making sure that we're
protecting our economy we're protecting
Social Security and Medicare this is
something that the American people spoke
very loud and clear and they did that
because of the success that this
president has had on his legislative
agenda because of the of what the
president has been able to deliver
because of what Democrats has been able
to do and making sure we had a sharp
message for the American people to see
the contrast right Republicans wanted to
put Social Security and Medicare on The
Chopping Block that's what they wanted
to do that was their plan uh and you
know people have said I've heard some of
your colleagues say earlier this morning
that stunning it was a stunningly bad
cycle for Republican Senators and a lot
of that is because of their agenda is
because they embodied the Ultra Maga
ideas and even with all of that the
American public came out and they put a
lot of that to rest a lot of what the
pre what the Republican officials were
putting forth their plan to rest and
they said it very loud and clear we want
to we want the special interests to pay
their fair share we want Social Security
we want Medicare to be protected and we
want women's rights to be protected as
well
thank you on Twitter Korean um the
Twitter files have released that the
company typically required an official
or law enforcement finding that
materials were hacked in order to
exercise their company policy to
restrict certain stories or reporting
and the journalists who released the
material noted that in this case around
the hunter Vine laptop story there was
no official or law enforcement finding
that appeared in the material that he
was given so my question to you is did
anyone from the Biden team
communicate to Twitter that this
material was um was from hap or this
reporting stem from hack materials are
you talking about the campaign it would
have been the campaign or anyone around
the family just wondering because
in the Twitter files release and what
Matt tabe said he noted that typically
the company would require a law
enforcement or official finding that
something was hacked in order to
exercise their hacked materials clause
and that they didn't he didn't see that
in what had been given to him so
wondering if it was communicated even
informally by someone around the
president or the president's family or
the campaign that this was hacked
material or could have come from hacked
material given that there was so much
concern especially after the 2018 born
interference situation that that could
be something that we would see in the in
that election so I'm wondering if there
was that communication there surrounding
the 100 by the laptops so I can't speak
to decisions made by uh by the campaign
from here that is not it is a political
uh campaign so I can't speak from that
from here to that from here I'm covered
by the Hatch Act and so I'm just not
going to comment on on the question that
you're asking me but what I can say more
broadly is of course it's up to these
companies to make their own decision
about the content on their platforms and
to ensure content follows their own
standards and policies but I'm just not
going to comment on a decision that was
made during the campaign
I have two questions for you following
the explosion near the border with
Ukraine Poland just accepted Germany's
offer to deploy Patriot missile defense
systems to Eastern Poland but initially
the Polish government said that Patriots
should be delivered to Ukraine so can
you comment on the deployment and I'm
wondering if the president sees a need
to transfer Patriots to Ukraine either
by NATO on the or the us considering
continued Russian attacks on civilian
infrastructure in Ukraine so to your
first question so we would leave it to
Germany and Poland to speak about the
specifics of what is being provided
that's for them their own governments to
speak to as a general matter we welcome
Allied efforts to bolster NATO's
Collective defenses and to your to your
last question about NATO and and how
this could be provided look we're in
close uh close uh contact with
ukrainians about their security
assistance needs as you've heard us
speak to many times from this Podium and
have been working to provide Ukraine
with air defense systems to help them
protect their country but I again I
don't have anything to to prove you
today for you today on this on that
particular show
government prime minister Victor Orban
said recently that Hungary will
ratify Sweden's and finland's membership
in NATO early next year does the
president have any update from Turkey
which it looks like will be the only
holdout
so look I would refer you to the Turkish
government to speak about their own
position it's certainly not something
that we're going to do from here but
what I can say is that we have been a
strong supporter of Finland and Sweden's
applications for a NATO membership and
work with the Senate to move quickly to
ratify their applications and so we have
welcomed the rapid ratifications by our
allies and we urge all remaining allies
to compete complete their own
ratification process as quickly as
possible
thanks great um are you guys confirming
reporting from Bloomberg today that the
president will travel to Mexico and meet
with Mexican president on January 9th
and hold a trilateral with Lopez obrador
and Trudeau on January 10th for the
North America we're still working
through the plans uh nothing has changed
since I was last asked this question and
we'll let you know if we have anything
more to share
details you can share about adding
bilateral meetings he's holding
um and given the focus of competition
with China and the National Security
strategy do you expect it to be a big
Topic at next week's Summit so I don't
have any bilateral meetings to share at
this time on on the Africa Summit leader
Summit that's happening next week as you
just stated we and I mentioned this a
little bit at the end of our of the
briefing on Monday we've invited 49
African heads of state to Washington DC
for a three-day Summit to highlight how
the U.S and African nations are
strengthening and our Partnerships to
advance uh shared shared priorities the
summit reflects the U.S strategy towards
sub-Saharan Africa with emphasis which
emphasizes the critical importance of
the region to meet this era's defining
challenges we will have more as we do
normally background calls and more to
share uh and uh and on what is to be
expected during those three day Summit
thanks Karen um my colleague had asked
you on Monday about the drug shortages
question and just wanted to follow up on
that is this something that the
president has been engaged in uh has he
been briefed on medicine shortages so
let me just say this in a share share
where we are
um so as I've said as you mentioned on
Monday I was asked by your colleague I
believe Ben the administration is
closely monitoring for the possibility
of any national shortages medicine
shortages are are not uncommon and is
closely monitored and led by FDA and HHS
who are experts on this right this is
their focus Health officials are in
close communication with manufacturers
around these medicines while we cannot
force a manufacturer to make more of any
drug the conversations have been focused
on understanding their supply and
production levels as well as as if
they're if there are any needs that we
can assist with to ensure steady supply
We Stand ready to help if there is a
need uh as also as part of these
conversation FDA and HHS are in touch
with manufacturing Associates who
continue to tell the public that they
are seeing strong Supply chains for
these products so that work again is
ongoing and as a reminder we stand ready
to help States and jurisdictions as they
face the Confluence of winter Illness
but also importantly we aggressively
pushing everyone to get their flu and
coveted shots I said this on Monday it
is important to do that is how folks are
going to protect themselves and their
families especially as we're going into
continuing the holiday season so we
stand ready to provide resources to
States like ventilators and PPE as well
as Personnel to help in hospitals just
last week secretary Becerra sent a
letter to the nation's Governors
reminding them to request those
resources if they need to if they need
it again this is something that FDA and
HSS is is managing but as I just stated
we are we are ready to help when needed
when those requests come in
agencies don't have much visibility into
supply chain issues they've said that
they're really dependent on the industry
to give them information on any issues
and whether there are shortages does the
White House think it's time for the FDA
to get more involved so that they can
get better information from companies
well I just stated in my my layout here
uh that FDA and HSS are in touch with
manufacturing Associates who continue to
tell to tell the public that they are
seeing strong Supply chains for these
products so that's what they're hearing
that's what we're all hearing from these
uh manufacturing associate associations
so I'll leave it I'll leave it there but
again I would refer you to FDA and HHS
as they are indeed the experts on this
but I've been very clear you saw
secretary becerra's letter that I just
laid out we are ready to help and we
have told states to certainly ask for
help if they need it and will it be
ready to act following up on that
question about whether concrete actions
are expected out of today's round table
on anything one of the Jewish groups
that participated was calling for
National strategy digressing issue but
another one of the President appoints
charges between the national election
Commons
[Music]
Point either those
um so that meeting just occurred I think
at 11 o'clock I don't have any a clear
readout on what uh on what was actually
asked or talked about I know you just
laid out a few things so we just need to
go back to our teams and see how we're
going to move forward don't want to get
ahead of what you know of what could be
what could be put forward on on the next
steps just don't want to get ahead of
that
yeah thanks uh thanks Karen on Tick Tock
I'm going to ask you about so Maryland
and South Dakota became the latest two
states to ban tick tock on state devices
is the federal government is the
president considering doing something
here so um I'm not going to comment on a
tick tock while a Sophia's uh the
committee on foreign investment in in
the United States uh review is ongoing
as you know to address concerns posed by
this particular app generally speaking
the bite Administration is focused on
challenge of certain of certain
countries including China seeking to
leverage digital Technologies in
America's data in ways that present
unacceptable National Security risk but
again I'm just not going to comment on
on a ongoing review there's one more on
President XI is now in Saudi Arabia
speaking with the king and the Crown
Prince
um there was much fanfare around his
visit does the president feel slighted
at all with his visit which didn't get
as much confidence circumstance
I'm sorry say that one more time so
there were dances and and Fanfare around
the visit from president XI coming in
the president didn't get the same kind
of reception uh in Saudi Arabia and I'm
wondering if there's any slightly they
met in Bali right with with when the
president went to Saudi Arabia to visit
the NBS like in the Crown Prince and so
your question is the question is does he
feel cited that there wasn't the same
kind of family no not at all we're going
to keep moving go ahead
first on ndaa something that wasn't in
the draft that got released today is
legislation to prevent a future
president or President Biden from
imposing a schedule F and moving gobs of
civil servants into the accepted service
would the president I won't ask you if
he'll he would veto uh the NBA without
it but would the president
support or encourage adoption of an
amendment to prevent this from happening
in the future it was one of the first
things he did as president so look I I
want to be very clear it's still you
know this is still in process
um we know you know one thing very
clearly with is the vaccine mandates and
they're still a process going a
legislative process going don't want to
get ahead of that so just not going to
to comment right now as there's
negotiations and and uh and this piece
of legislation is still moving through
the second uh their reports in the last
air show that the president is poised to
appoint a new Northern Ireland Envoy but
that Envoy would focus more on economic
development than the brexit Northern
Ireland protocol border situation if the
the envoy will not be focused on that
does the president plan to get more
involved to ensure a smooth
implementation of the Good Friday
agreement the 25th anniversary is coming
up in a matter of months I'm not going
to get ahead of of the special Envoy and
what their what their purview is going
to be or not be I'm just not going to
get ahead of that okay thank you Karine
I just wanted to follow up on Tick Tock
I know you said you can't comment but
the U.S business operations of the
company have effectively been in
question for nearly three years and I'm
wondering at what point you think there
might be an outcome one way or another
on whether it can operate here I'm just
not gonna comment on an ongoing review
that Sophia's is doing uh and uh as you
know the review is is ongoing to address
the concerns posed by the app I'm just
not going to comment from here the FBI
director has said publicly on Capitol
Hill that it does pose a national con
security concern but company Executives
said just yesterday they believe they're
on a path to resolve those concerns so
does the administration have a view on
whether those concerns can be resolved
so look I talked about the challenges uh
that we that are for are certain that we
that we're currently seeing so I can say
this more broadly that we're taking the
steps we can to address these types of
challenges for example President Biden
issue the first diverse Presidential
Directive defining additional National
Security factors for sypheus to consider
in the in line with this
administration's National Security
priorities like protecting America's
sensitive data and last year President
Biden put forward an executive order to
protect Americans sensitive sensitive
data from collect collection and
utilization the Commerce Department with
interagency support is working to
implement this EO and utilize other
related authorities and we will continue
to look at other actions that we can
take on this on this matter but I'm just
not going to comment on this specific
issue voting rights are there any
specific elements of either the
electoral count act or the John Lewis
Voting Rights Act that the White House
is seeking to add on to any year-end
spending bill can you say the first part
of your question on Voting Rights Voting
Rights has obviously been a huge
priority of this Administration and
there's a suggestion that there could be
some
type of voting rights push here in the
final weeks of the year that some
elements of existing legislation could
be added on to a year-end spending bill
has the White House been discussing this
with leadership so I I've spoken to this
a little bit about the about the
importance of um of the president
supporting uh the Electoral the
Electoral piece I don't have anything
else to share on that we're going to let
Congress continue to negotiate and move
forward with how they're moving uh of
the next couple of weeks but don't have
anything specifics I haven't seen any
language or anything specific about what
you're asking on voting rights and
others
all right I'll see you guys tomorrow
thanks everybody
[Music]